[Music]
it's one of the most distinctive
buildings in the world but it's losing
part of what made it famous after
decades of work to keep the Leaning
Tower of Pisa and Italy from toppling
over scientists discovered this week
that quite the opposite is happening
Seth Doane has the story
tourists have been using cameras in the
power of perspective to push up the
tower at least as an illusion but
engineers have been at work for about
two decades to actually stop the famed
Tuscan bell tower from Leaning now it's
stabilizing and straightening just a bit
the 186 foot Leaning Tower of Pisa is
tilting an inch and a half less than it
was about two decades ago it's endlessly
less earth on the opposite side from how
it's leaning roberto cella explained the
tower has reacted by straightening out
the marble bell tower a tribute to the
one-time strength of the republic of
pisa started tilting soon after
construction began back in 1173 it was
closed to the public in 1990 eleven
years later it was reopened after an
ambitious restoration project to attach
braces and weights to the structure
while removing soil from one side to
allow it to straighten this civil
engineering professor studying how the
tower was able to withstand strong
earthquakes explained the ground beneath
particularly thick and the sole the
whole structure is very stiff and the
third characteristic is the particularly
soft ground because of the place used to
be a river a river that doesn't exist
anymore in fact the word Pisa is ancient
Greek for marshy land at this pace it
could still take thousands of years for
it to completely straighten so fear not
those poses and photo ops should still
be possible for many generations to come
for CBS this morning Saturday Seth Doane
Rome very definition of